hello and welcome to this video yes in
five minute game and we see that heavy
favorite yeah it's a little bit
difficult at the moment you get get
games and there are so many people
probably playing at the chess olympiad
you cannot imagine okay so we'll see
what happens marble revealer um yeah
since he's out 4593 is interesting i can
also go dear forum context I this is a
this is a somewhat questionable decision
I think I'll tonight beehive now so hmm
it was a very quick decision so Luke c6
is the thing interesting
um Queen to c7 settled Quincy 70
probably will go Quinn to be eight wow
that's very strange n look sec says
something else that I can do here Quincy
78 it looks very strange but I don't
quite see how to if I can be viewed it
on the other hand is not threatening and
that much so maybe just a Rube move me a
69 is maybe threatening a six hmm i
think it could have only six that
wouldn't have been all that grade ok
let's see night back to age
now i think i'm going to open open this
up here so i may be a six i keep
forgetting about that a six move him
keep forgetting about this he takes
default Oh take 25 maybeee for was was
something for him I mean it shouldn't be
completely forgotten that I've the much
better development him I've got
basically all pieces in play and he
still has Luke on a eight bishop on CL
even though well I can take care right
that also diffuses Bishop f5 and I'm
ready to play me forward to support the
night of it is needed Wow
that diagonal looks very scary very
scary on the dark squares ok so we
counter at xt5 I go night before does
that nobody for bishops hanging ok so
just before then keep it simple 94 I've
got Queenie Freud's useful
yeah I need a battery on the lawn agonal
like Bishop a one Queen V to that looks
very scary if i can get it get this
going down if we go to him to organize
maybe 927 covering if 60 bit more I know
it doesn't really have yeah I can take
with the Queen right
whoopee 8 is Bishop b5 black resigns hmm
there was a funky defense there with
rookie 6 I mean this is a theoretical
position rates which is supposed to be
excellent for white cookies sex can I
yeah the engine wants to do this but I
didn't really find I didn't really see
something brilliant here computer just
wants to play looks ammonia maybe this
is strong here threatens 96 and is a
strong of course and this is what I
should have done yeah I can't stop
wishes on 1.5 winning 87 and that was
much stronger now this isn't all that
great yeah I should have played Quincy 7
the rukon c6 doing a good defensive job
98 and d4 is actually somewhat question
but i forgot about a six again and he
could have played it before now i mean i
don't think i should be worse here
because of my development so something
something like this should be okay
somehow hell that I'm not in trouble all
my pieces play and he's still kind of
behind yeah this is also supported by
the engine engine wants to play this now
to keep the material but this is always
good compensation of the dark squares
still not what I I mean by far not what
was possible yeah this on the other hand
looks excellent again Jim here this is a
this is a winning position I could have
taken on c5 actually how I didn't see
that I mean I saw her saw that but I
didn't calculate up to this point that
I'm actually threatening to take with
the book so something like that is
rooty five okay that would have one bit
okay the position is so good that didn't
matter all that much no Luke p8 we
should be five this is a um simple you
just simply won't ending as i get da
porn okay well thanks for watching